voilà une illustration de ce que fut
cette guerre illustrations qui va nous
servir de point d'entrée pour parler de
l'algérie d'aujourd'hui la guerre laisse
des traces
qu'en reste-t-il dans la société
algérienne qu'elle est la continuité
historique entre ces événements et les
événements que vit aujourd'hui l'algérie
avec d abdelaziz bouteflika c'est la
génération de l'indépendance qui quitte
le pouvoir les jeunes générations vont
elles pas revenir à tourner cette page
douloureuse nous allons maintenant en
parler avec nos invités bonjour à vous
pierre vermeren
bonjour vous êtes historien du maghreb
contemporain
bonjour neila latrous vous êtes
rédactrice en chef à jeune afrique
or pour le maghreb et le moyen-orient
face à vous une naoufel brahim brahimi
el mili bonjour bonjour politologue et
bonjour à vous jean charles geoffrey
jour professeur émérite d'histoire
contemporaine à sciences po aix et
peut-être commencer par vous
jean-charles geoffrey réaction d'abord à
ce que nous venons de voir à ce
documentaire on se rend compte à quel
point cette guerre a dit viser non
seulement bien sûr français et algériens
mais français entre eux et algériens
entre eux alors le documentaire est très
intéressant il est bon et courageux
quelques erreurs de dates on va pas
entrer dans le détail mais ce
documentaire a le mérite de vous montrer
la complexité d'une guerre c'est pas
seulement entre combattants entre
terroristes et ceux qui torturent c'est
une guerre qu sur le plan psychologique
qui va dans ses derniers retranchements
et notamment le cas du pôle un léger et
tout à fait remarquablement interprété
analyser un homme que vous avez
rencontrées je les ai rencontrés le 12
octobre 1996 sur un terrain neutre à
liverpool et il m'a livré un témoignage
qui n'est pas dans le témoignage qui est
dans le film enregistré deux ans plus
tard au derby historique
c'est un élément parallèle il s'agit de
l'un de ses plus beaux coups et dans son
livre au carrefour de la guerre il n'en
parle pas je vais vous donner la clé à
la fin 1957 n'a pas précisé la date ses
services entre guillemets récupère
également guillaume et en a un gros
poisson
il devine que c'est un officier de la
wilaya iii
il décide donc dans un premier temps
comme le montre documentaire de leur
tournée puis n'y parvient pas il s'est
dit bien je ne peux pas obtenir de cet
homme qui est un honnête homme le fait
qu'il soit retourné alors il a gardé dix
jours et pendant dix jours il a reçu en
camarades
on a parlé de l'appui du beau temps à
chaque fois ils disent aimer tu veux me
dire quelque chose on le tutoie mois
intervient l'autre était muet et pendant
dix jours petit déjeuner repas de midi
repas du soir
et puis j'abrège au bout de dix jours il
dit maintenant tu m'a rien dit je suis
désolée c'est la prison barberousse et
par rapport à l'endroit où se trouvait
le pc de légers dans la basse casbah
il sait ce que ça veut dire on va le
charcuter peu après c'est la tête coupée
certainement
donc ils s'arrangent pour qui une fausse
évasion le passe aussi sur les détails
qu'est ce qui se passe cet officier de
la wilaya iii réussi à se faire
exfiltrer par les réseaux internes du
fln puis quand il arrive devant le
colonel amirouche dont on parle
évidemment dans leur hymne j'abrège
aussi des traces de torture il y en ait
pas mais dis donc a pris 2,3 kg or comme
il est et je dirais un personnage
important d'une des sous secteurs de la
ville et à 3 il a été torturé
tous ceux qui étaient autour de lui on
était torturé éliminé si tunis est
calculée par saddam que l'on voit dans
le documentaire à lundi à l'ats il y
passe je voudrais qu'on parle de la
guerre à proprement parler ces
opérations elles ont elles ont joué un
rôle vraiment important militairement
militairement parlant ces opérations
d'infiltration là dessus oui évidemment
ce documentaire montre la supériorité de
la puissance de feu de l'armée française
et et de larmes psychologique
le chiffre donné ici par le capital
léger la bleuite aurait fait 4000
victimes
c'est un chiffre c'est plus oui voilà
c'est un chiffre déjà interpellant
sachant qu'à l'indépendance il n'y avait
qu'un millier de bacheliers algérien
donc c'est l'élite qui est décapité
alors c'est très intéressant est
d'ailleurs vrai qu'on regarde à nouveau
ce court extrait
jusque là c'est l'un des aspects les
plus intéressants du film l'un de ceux
qui a été victime de cette opération
rémy madoui a été lui même torturé par
ses propres camarades et voici comment
il parle de la bleuite et conséquences
de la bleuite ses qualités la raison ou
la source de l'extermination de toute la
jeunesse algérienne et du cac 40 et
l'avenir de l'algérie
c'est un gâchis
je crois donc tous les domaines aux
humains beaucoup plus qu'autre chose ce
peuple là si ça n'avait pas fini
quelques cela était qu'elle paie ce
serait aujourd'hui ça veut donc dire que
cette opération a laissé des traces
pendant des années parce que ce que dit
rémi madoui peut-être aussi discutable
c'est sombre c'est un sentiment mais ce
que historiquement c'est vrai ce qui est
certain ce qui est certain cette
opération là à enrayer la machine à
fabriquer les élites
sachant que quand quand ya eu l'appel
des étudiants à rejoindre les maquis
c'est essentiellement des lycéens
il y avait très peu d'étudiants des
lycéens donc encore très jeune encore
très jeune et et là on voit ce document
fait réagir parce que en algérie le
colonel amirouche est un héros à juste
titre il est mort en héros et le dogme
révolutionnaire c'est la révolution il
n'y en prend pas de risque et c'est la
pureté révolutionnaire dont le sens le
plus absolu
même si des innocents meurent ça ça vous
emmener au sujet qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est à dire la continuité
historique qui lie à entre qu'il y
aurait entre la guerre d'algérie et les
événements que nous nous vivons
aujourd'hui que l'algérie vit
aujourd'hui pierre vermeren vous voyez
quoi dans deux seulement dans cette
continuité historique
écoutez la destruction de cette jeunesse
diplômée parce que faut se remettre dans
le contexte des années 50 et 60 un
bachelier c'était quelqu'un qui avait un
très bon niveau
c'était des garçons qui venait des
villes donc plutôt de la bourgeoisie
souvent enfin en tout cas d et donc
c'est le fait que ces jeunes aient été
décimée dans les maquis pour des raisons
il ya une dimension sociale d'une
dimension anti intellectuel il ya une
dimension aussi amis rouges qui est
entouré par une toute une paysannerie
qui se méfie de ces bourgeois qui ont
trahi qui ont collaboré avec la france
depuis toujours bon bon ça fait remonter
des choses à la surface et au fond ça
participe donc delà de la fragilisation
vous aviez d'un coup les d'un côté les
coups de boutoir de l'armée française
par le plan challe etc de l'autre cette
autodestruction intérieur et finalement
ceux qui vont ramasser la mise c'est pas
seul c'est pas ces gens là c'est ceux
qui sont à l'extérieur c'est l'armée des
frontières c'est bouteflika pour faire
le joint avec l'actualité
ce qui était un auxiliaire de boumédiène
et donc c'est l'armée des frontières qui
va récupérer la mise parce que les
maquis ont été détruits ou autodétruit
est donc évidemment et en + 100 suspects
et donc il ya une véritable reconquête
de l'algérie entre guillemets à l'été 62
qui fait quand même mille morts
encore mille personnes des maquis qui
meurt vous avez un certain nombre
probablement des deux personnalités même
des maquis de la wilaya iii qui vont
quitter l'algérie en soit c'est
absolument quand ils étaient 62 juste
après les ports donc voilà donc et
effectivement les gens qui arrivent au
pouvoir
eh bien ils viennent de le quitter à
travers la personnalité bouteflika le 2
avril je crois 2019
neila latrous vous entendre là dessus
aussi parce qu'on a on a du mal quand
même à se dire que ces élites
algériennes qui aurait été décapité au
cours des opérations dont nous avons
entendu parler d'eux dans le
documentaire on
on sent bien que c'est aussi quelque
chose qui sert d'une certaine manière le
le discours de du pouvoir et du fln
depuis 1962 tout ça c'est la faute de la
guerre c'est la faute de la colonisation
c'est la faute de la france c'est la
faute de la guerre de la france de la
colonisation effectivement à entendre le
fln mais ce qui est intéressant quand on
regarde aujourd'hui la façon dont ces
structures et l'algérie depuis 1962
on perçoit que d'une certaine façon
cette dichotomie entre la force pure de
l'armée des chars cette pureté
révolutionnaire comme l'évoqué naofel et
d'un autre côté une élite qui qui
essaieraient de penser à un autre pays
qu'il soit du point de vue économique
politique sociétale et c'est dichotomie
elles existent encore aujourd'hui
l'analyse qui est la mienne face aux
événements c'est que in fine l armée
arrive au bout d'un moment en disant
c'est sympa vos trucs d'intello là où on
réfléchit à quelle est la suite du pays
mais enfin bon il ya une vérité qui est
celle de l'armée qui est celle de
l'ordre on va reprendre la main aux
grosses structures ce qui se passe
derrière et puis s'il ya besoin de
sacrifier une ou deux élites avocat des
droits de l'homme hommes d'affaires etc
c'est pas grave parce qu'au fond ce qui
est intéressant c'est de revenir à la
pureté n'ont pas de 62 mais de novembre
54 et ce qui est également assez
frappant quand on regarde ce qui se
passe dans la rue naoufel évoqué les
jeunes les lycéens
l'appel au maquis il se trouve que mardi
à alger il y avait encore une
manifestation d'étudiants et de lycéens
et ce qu'ils revendiquent est et les
valeurs de novembre 54 donc
effectivement de rejeter tout ce qui a
pu se passer pendant cette guerre
d'algérie de revenir à la purée sens de
ce que devait être un pays indépendant
et libre et et au final c'est assez
curieux de voir comme l'histoire peut se
répéter quelques quelques décennies plus
tard et cette mémoire donc laisse des
traces
en 1999 l'arrivée au pouvoir de
bouteflika vous vous la lisez d'une
certaine manière comme la continuité de
déçus de la guerre faut bien expliquer
ça parce que les téléspectateurs ont pas
forcément d'aller vite et des suites de
la course pouvoir après la guerre de
l'été les soirs de l'été 62 points très
précis il faut bien se dire alors
évidemment cette version de l'histoire
elle n'est pas connue par les jeunes
algériens aujourd'hui sauf s'ils en ont
entendu parler dans leur famille mais
pour rebondir sur ce que disaient les là
bien sûr que les références qui sont
faites par les jeunes algériens
aujourd'hui dans la rue à ce qui se
passe ils ont été eux comment dirais-je
j'allais dire gaver mais c'est pas un
bonnet en mémoire de la guerre d'algérie
donc c'est très présent pour eux parce
que on leur a asséné à travers la
télévision les médias le cinéma et
l'école cette histoire de manière très
unilatérale très incomplète bon mais
elle produit ses effets elle produit ses
effets actuellement ce qu on appelle l
irak
c'est à dire le mouvement c'est le new
age et rier ce sont des jeunes qui en
ont assez de la rente mémorielle sur
laquelle le système s'est établie et ces
jeunes enfin le sentiment qu'ils
touchent que la génération de 62 aurait
touché c'est le chef de la liberté pour
une guerre de libération qui a coûté
très cher et c'est eux qui vont
encaisser j'espère ce chèque
entre temps vous avez eu un pays qui est
un pays qui n'a aucun équivalent dans le
monde en tant que régime
on peut le traiter de régimes policiers
ont prêté tout ce que vous voulez dire
ils fondés il était fondée uniquement
sur cette notion d'hyper commémoration
il n'était pas question de parler
d'histoire du 1er novembre 54 et s'était
rien passé avant ou très peu et puis
c'était uniquement une version monocorde
et là les jeunes maintenant n'en veulent
plus grasset passionnant parce que l'on
va on va regarder un extrait vous nous
avez dit voilà qu'à une rente mémorielle
vous nous avez dit qu'il ya une jeunesse
qui a été biberonné à une mémoire deux
événements qu'elle n'a pas connu et
alors on voulait vous faire regarder
cette scène qui est très connu
c'était en décembre 2017 emmanuel macron
visite en algérie est lui qui n'a pas
connu évidemment les événements est face
à quelqu'un qui les a pas connu non plus
à regarder cette scène qui ont fait les
belles choses mais qui ont fait des
choses atroces mais on a fait plus fort
encore
mais moi j'en suis pas prisonnier pong
avec l âge
une génération
elle doit regarder la voilà cette
génération doit regarder l'avenir
n'empêche que effectivement elle a
toujours la tête ont passé elle a
tellement la tête dans le passé que dans
les manifestations on voit des portraits
de révolutionnaire on voit larbi
benmhidi ont salué djamila bouhired
lorsqu'elle descend je crois que
d'ailleurs la soeur de larbi ben m'hidi
était aussi dans les manifestations etc
etc des personnalités qui sont applaudis
qui sont glorifiés alors que
effectivement je suis d'accord mais
idéalisé sans doute aussi parce que je
ne suis pas sûr que cette histoire de
l'algérie soit aussi bien connu que cela
par la génération bouteflika c'est à
dire celles nées après 1980 18 et qui au
final était dans la rue rapidement pour
revenir aussi sur le rôle de la france
et 7 et 7 traces car cette opération
d'infiltration dans les esprits
aujourd'hui encore enfin on est
oui plus d'un demi siècle après la fin
de la guerre d'algérie lorsque dans la
dernière ligne et il s'agit de faire des
missionnaires des nazis bouteflika on
évoque une réunion un complot des
services secrets algériens avec dit-on
mais service français évidemment
démentie par l'ambassade de france mais
on reste dans cette idée pardon
d'infiltration on reste toujours dans
l'idée que ce serait la france la france
qui était réel et fils l expression
consacrée la main de l'étranger qui
généralement désigne la vue pour revenir
à une date qui revient enfin cette date
elle est aussi important que le 1er
novembre 1954 elle revient maintenant
dans la rue
c'est ce qu'on appelle la plateforme de
la soummam pour la fin d'un colloque qui
s'est tenu en basse kabylie de tous les
chefs de la résistance la vraie
intérieur et qui projetait l'algérie de
la libération
le pouvoir actuel avait toujours mis de
côté en vous n'en voulez pas entendre
parler
et c'est cette promesse d'une algérie
sans référence à la religion entre
autres c'était une promesse une algérie
résolument tournée vers le progrès vers
sa jeunesse qui revient enfin ça c'est
une sacrée revanche en fait juste sera
propre au delà de la soummam le drame
finalement de la guerre d'algérie c'est
d'avoir décimé le la classe politique
algérienne qui était très riche très
abondante très diversifiées allant du
parti communiste et des mini trotskiste
même jusqu'aux courants les plus
nationalistes de toutes sortes ou les
plus religieux et finalement les gens
qui ont pris le pouvoir se sont pas des
gens qui ont fait de la politique se
sont pas des idéologues sont des gens
qui sont des soldats en réalité ou des
paysans et c'est vrai qu'il ya une perte
en ligne considérable et ce phénomène de
la bleuite il a contribué en décimant la
jeunesse éduquée fort mais voilà mes
jeux pour rebondir juste une dernière
chose sur ce que disait à nouveau les là
le la maladie française on dit souvent
que c'est la commémoration de notre
histoire on est mais il ya un pic est
encore plus malades que nous c'est
l'algérie tout à fait naoufel brahim el
mili povera l'histoire depuis les années
2000 jusqu'à maintenant il ya un
événement important en algérie c'est le
salon du livre
le salon du livre
pour faire court il ya deux catégories
de livres que les gens achètent les
livres sur la guerre de libération et
livres sur la religion
déjà ça ça vous tue tout dire pour
revenir à la bleuite et sa continuité
dans les rapports franco algérien juste
après la bleuite ya eu ce phénomène qui
jouxte qui n'a rien à voir les
déserteurs de l'armée française il ya eu
des officiers des nationalistes qui ont
fait fuir de libération par conviction
mais le fait qu'ils aient été sous les
drapeaux avec d'une manière peut-être
subconsciente de la bleuite on les a
considérés dans une petite majorité
comme étant des infiltrés tout à fait
depuis il ya eu ce clivage les anciens
de la ln et les anciens déserteurs de
l'armée française
et là on se rend compte encore une fois
à quel point les divisions évidemment on
produit de la défiance de part et
d'autre et au sein au sein de chaque
camp je voudrais qu'on parle parce qu'on
parle de la guerre de la guerre
d'indépendance depuis depuis tout à
l'heure mais on sent bien que il ya une
mémoire qui pour le coup semble
totalement occulté alors que les
événements sont beaucoup plus récent et
sans être aussi meurtrier ils sont
terribles c'est ceux de la décennie
noire
on en parle oui aujourd'hui dans
l'algérie d'aujourd'hui dans celles qui
défilent mais il a la trouille mais on
en parle alors c'est intéressant parce
que autant cette période de la guerre
d'algérie est extrêmement compliqué à
traiter notamment pour les journalistes
pour les historiens pour les le monde de
la culture c'est à dire si vous voulez
faire un film aujourd'hui un peu qu'ils
sortent du récit officiel sur larbi ben
m'hidi par exemple c'est un exemple qui
qui a eu cours vous ne m'ayez pire
en revanche ils n'ont en revanche vous
pouvez faire des films sur la sur la
décennie noire il ya beaucoup moins de
problèmes un certain nombre de camarades
producteurs me disent on est beaucoup
moins gêné par exemple par le ministère
des des moudjahidine des anciens
combattants qui doit délivrer son
autorisation si vous voulez faire un
film sur la guerre d'algérie mais qui va
pas intervenus il faut une autorisation
en algérie encore aujourd'hui comme
mario soit validé par le ministre des
anciens combattants et le connais tes
précisions parce que c'est le ministère
des anciens moujahidine qui financent
donc il valide mais donc du coup il a
son mot à dire mais sur la décennie
noire en revanche n'ont rien de tel et
vous avez une liberté de récits qui qui
va
au delà à quelques exceptions près
notamment sur le rôle qu'ont pu jouer le
renseignement pour intéressant
d'ailleurs puisque le renseignement
algérien a repris à son compte un
certain nombre de méthodes de de l'armée
française lors de la guerre d'algérie et
notamment la bleuite le fait de
retourner des islamistes qui était dans
les maquis contre leur propre camp ou de
laisser à penser qu'ils allaient puce
corrompre avec le pouvoir pour
qu'ensuite il faut détruire
s'autodétruisent c'est des techniques
qui ont été utilisés en fuite ont
atteint 90 c'est très intéressant
simplement à ce que ce que je voulais
comprendre c'est est ce que finalement
cette instrumentalisation de la mémoire
de la guerre d'algérie n'a pas servi à
occulter une certaine manière cette
décennie noire
non mais il ya autre chose c'est pas
seulement une une manipulation une
occultation
c'est bon c'est vrai que la guerre
civile du désert des mères elle a
rejoint il ya eu un effet miroir ne
serait-ce que pas à travers les slogans
en dix ans et les nouveaux colons qui
sont au pouvoir
d'ailleurs je rappelle que les dans les
premiers jours des manifestations cette
année bouteflika l'homme des français
rentre chez toi ou sous-entendus au
maroc etc
donc c'est cela c'est de là qu'il vient
appuyer bouteilles cassées le clan
d'oujda vous tenez marocains ils
affrontent ou résider l'armée des
frontières et au résident est aussi le
mal que c'est à dire les services
secrets de l'armée dirigée par boussouf
et ça c'est aussi un héritage très
important de la bleuite parce que cette
guerre de l'ombre entre les services
secrets français et les services secrets
algériens
donc elle a rendu les l'armée algérienne
paranoïaque totalement puisqu'il se
disait tout toute personne dans nos
rangs et susceptibles d'être un traître
au service de la france et donc de nous
de nous détruire de nous faire
disparaître et c'est ici où là il aurait
l'air dépasse évidemment parce
qu'aujourd'hui qui aujourd'hui dire et
qui jusqu'à nos jours quand les
algériens pendant des décennies on dit
le système ils disent la sécurité
militaire ensuite c'est le drs et puis
aujourd'hui c'est qui alors bouteflika
en 2015 soit disant à démanteler le
service le drs et hier on lit dans la
presse que l'armée tout de suite à
reconstituer réunifiée rappellerai
l'alarmé les directives
la direction du renseignement et de la
sécurité voilà donc voilà donc c'est
cette histoire de 60 ans d'omniprésence
des services de renseignement est l'une
de ces sources
c'est justement cette paranoïa liés à la
bleuite pendant la décennie noire il y à
un événement une tragédie c'est un
attentat dans un cimetière de l'ouest
algérien où les enfants des chouhada
commémorer le 1er novembre il y avait
une bande et tout de suite on a dit
c'est les attentats commis par les
enfants des harkis voilà parce que dans
cette région là il y avait des harkis
notables qui ont quitté ou bien qui sont
morts et le fait de deux mètres une
bande lors d'une commémoration des
martyrs du 1er novembre
c'est les harkis donc c'est la main de
l'étranger même pendant la décennie
noire où c'est vrai pour le dise noir la
france on peut lui reprocher sa non
collaboration avec les militaires
algériens mais l'infiltration les
attentats la france a commis des
attentats en algérie une autre période
sous boumédiène mais plus de pluie et
l'a donc ce sont les est requis pour le
rôle qu'ils ont joué aux côtés de la
france pendant la guerre qui sont qui
sont alors mis en cause qui sont pointés
du doigt dans l'imaginaire que des
classes que c'est devenu un an
génériques ou et toutes personnes
susceptibles d'avoir collaboré les
berbéristes harkis articles etc
si l'enfant n'est pas sage le soir
attention on appelle l'art qui a oui oui
c'est le tchétchène pour les russes
nabeul qui va venir vont manger on met
tout dedans on distingue pas le harkis
supplétifs du tirailleur algérien
disparu militaire c'est toujours là
c'est dommage mais c'est toujours là
mais elle est la décennie noire de que
vous évoquez elle a ouvert une seconde
phase 2 de rupture aussi entre entre
l'intelligencia algérienne et la france
la lecture française à l'époque
politique était celle d'islamistes qui
était non pas des terroristes mais des
réfugiés politiques des personnes
persécutées et un certain nombre ont pu
être accueillis en france aujourd'hui
quand vous discutez avec un responsable
algérien et vous dire la france au final
a servi de base arrière aux terroristes
qui venaient nous nous attaquer nous a
par ailleurs décrédibiliser en laissant
à penser que que les attentats étaient
commis par des organes du pouvoir et ça
a créé à mon sens
une blessure encore plus grave que celle
de 54 62 auprès d'un certain nombre de
responsables et notamment militaires en
vous écoutant on se rend compte à quel
point cette fête défiance elles
continuent elles continuent
d'empoisonner la société algérienne mais
évidemment aussi la relation entre la
france et l'algérie très rapidement oui
un mot pour dire que effectivement c'est
très paradoxal ce point de vue en même
temps parce que le pays notamment à
l'époque de charles pasqua qui a soutenu
l'algérie en guerre contre le fils
c'était quand même la france l'union
soviétique était avait disparu les
américains négocier avec le fils pour
prévoir son arrivée au pouvoir
d'installer du salut on rappelle juste
quand même un peu les téléspectateurs le
front islamique du salut la victoire
mais voilà il faut quand même rappeler
les ennemis donc effectivement il ya à
la fois l'ennemi et la miss élaguer
c'est l'ennemi intérieur mais c'est
aussi la mine tous mélangés ça fait
quelque chose de franco-algériens de
particulièrement complète il faut qu'on
parle maintenant de 2 voilà de faucon
posé cette question où va l'algérie est
ce que cette page cette mémoire
empoisonné il est possible de certaines
manières de s'en débarrasser de tourner
c'est page extrêmement douloureuse vrai
quand même via voit d'où l'on vient nous
convient qu'on prenne la mesure de ce
que représente le départ d'abdel aziz
bouteflika regardez ces images
d'archivés nous sommes en 1963
en plus des solutions financières
nous avons procédé
à une clarification considérable de
l'atmosphère politique
du conteur contentieux en quelque sorte
qui existait entre l'algérie et la
france
voilà donc abdelaziz bouteflika déjà
ministre en 1963 est ce qu'on est
vraiment sûr que cette fois cette
génération va passer la main
l'internaute un mot sur c'est un des
rares lycéens qui n'a pas été décimés
par la bleuite s'il y en a eu d'autres
mais parce qu'ils étaient marocains en
99 il est venu avec le projet de la
réconciliation nationale la concorde
nationale c'est l'amnistié aux
islamistes pour mettre tout sous le
tapis on n'en parle plus avec ce qui se
passe maintenant quand on voit dans la
foule les islamistes sans trop invisible
pour ne pas exister
on s'interroge vous dites que derrière
tout cela
ils sont en seraient en embuscade
derrière les manifestations des
islamistes sont des gens quasiment
normaux ils sont opportunistes comme
tout le monde je voudrais vous poser la
question n'est là la trousse puisqu'on
parle des élites algériennes qui aurait
été décimée qui ont été décimés à la
suite de la guerre d'algérie elles sont
où aujourd'hui qui qui aujourd'hui
recrute enfin elles sont recrutées ou
ses élites algériennes dans l'algérie
d'aujourd'hui
alors quand on parle des lip parle
politique économique politique des
élites politiques et économiques
ou est ce que le pouvoir se régénère
s'il en a les moyens
a aujourd'hui le pouvoir n'est à mon
sens pas dans une logique de
régénération l'élite militaire et bien
se recrutent dans les académies
militaires qui qui existent en algérie
et dans le lot de ceux qui sont formés à
l'étranger si on regarde l'état major
aujourd'hui soit dit en passant on parle
de tourner la page de cette de cette
légitimité révolutionnaire pas au sein
de l'état major au sein de l'état-major
tout le monde est un moudjahid tout le
monde a fait ses armes à commencer par
le chef d'état major qui se présentent
dans les différents courriers comme un
moudjahid un glorieux nos glorieux
martyrs et c'est donc au niveau de
l'élite militaire on est plutôt sur une
doxa russie-biélorussie tchécoslovaquie
egypte quand on regarde la formation
aujourd'hui de l'état major on est
plutôt dans cette
dans cette école là si on parle la
france années 80 ça commençait la
coopération la france il ya eu des
militaires formés en france et aux états
unis
ça m'excite est plutôt simple de la
communauté du renseignement et à leur
police mais pour les élites politiques
économie et jolie de politique écoles
sont un peu plus occidentalisé pour le
coup quand il s'agit de des libéraux
dont il voyait plutôt proche de
l'angleterre les états unis la france et
ses pensées politiques plus
conservatrices islamistes puisque faut
savoir que nous de france on voit
beaucoup ceux qui s'expriment en
français mais il ya que 60 70 80 % de la
classe politique qui elle est plutôt
arabophones et qui est plutôt branché
vers l'est du continent africain donc
émirats qatar arabie saoudite etc sur
les élites économiques
elle se recrutent essentiellement au
sein de ceux qui ont les moyens
d'envoyer leurs enfants faire des études
ou des formations à l'étranger donc au
sein d'une banque la thur donc si je
vous écoute bien aujourd'hui l'armée
vont continuer de tenir une place
prépondérante et d'une certaine manière
c'est elle qui détient toutes les clés
pour la suite rahman bas en tout cas ça
ne se fera pas sans elle ne sait pas si
elle détient toutes les clés mais elle
elle est suffisamment puissante à la
fois par son ombre par son budget par
ces moyens par son histoire sa
légitimité et sa place dans la société
six cent mille militaires avec leurs
familles sans parler des cinq cent mille
fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'intérieur
vous avez une espèce de blocs
sécuritaire qui fait peut-être j'ai pas
8 millions 10 millions de personnes
ces voix là c'est en plus qui ont la
légitimité historique avec eux et qu'ils
ont la force
bon voilà donc soit l'armée est en tout
cas laissé dirigeants parce que c'est
dire c'est un système hiérarchisé soient
ses dirigeants veulent accompagner le
peuple algérien vers sa démocratisation
soit au bout d'un moment ils vont se
dire pour une raison pour une autre
c'est dangereux on bloque mais
effectivement si les volants la volonté
très partagés très présente aujourd'hui
dans les manifestations de la population
algérienne d'aller à cette seconde
indépendance démocratique cette fois
et ne fait pas de doute l'armée a les
moyens de la compagnie ou de la bloquer
passé par et l'armée de la nation
pourquoi que cette armée est encore
composer pour l'armée de terre de 300
mille hommes c'est la plus puissante
après celle de l'egypte mais à peu près
la moitié un peu plus ce sont des
appelés ce qui veut dire que le général
gaïd salah ne pouvait pas faire
n'importe quoi
d'autant que l'image de marque de
l'algérie et ça c'est l'essentiel pour
moi est extraordinaire c'est pas de
gilet jaune
il va là et après les manifestations
d'image de marque de lingerie elle est
positive est vrai que ça ne se fera
pression nous sommes dans un système qui
me fait un peu frémir vu les capacités à
rebondir du fln et des différents
services qui tourne autour de la police
politique ou des renseignements
je vous rappelle que si vous deviez
faire un pronostic vous vos
interrogations parce qu'attention je
vous rappelle qu'il ya eu un précédent
avant la chute du mur de berlin 1989
vous poser la question il ya quand même
eu 500 morts mais pendant deux ans ont
marché vers une démocratie et donc on a
inventé un terrorisme islamique
on a inventé le fils on a inventé x
attentats je sais pas ce que ça plombe
dans des racines algériennes profonde
mais on a instrumentalisé le fils le
fils a peut être été réalisés mais enfin
il faut pas non plus
on est peut-être dans une optique dormez
bonnes gens vous protège on attendra
peut-être qu'on apprendra un grand
attentes en a à g ou ailleurs dans les
jours qui viennent et à son vocable le
pouvoir compenser monribot reprendra du
service risques pour est plus
sécuritaire avec la suède
c'est un des points d'interrogation en
tout cas le commandement militaire est
composée de combattants qui savent
reconnaître un rapport de force
aujourd'hui le rapport de forces est en
faveur des manifestants qui se chiffrent
15 millions ça dépend dé vendredi
donc jusqu'à ce jour c'est le peuple
algérien qui est encore maître des
horloges pour reprendre une expression
connue en france par la suite
est-ce qu'il va est ce que le
commandement militaire va essayer de
faire un passage en force en imposant
une
lecture stricte de la constitution
ladite constitution a été violée par le
président de la république le 11 mars
dernier quand il a annoncé le report d
annulation des élections
donc on n'a pas d'assise juridique la
constitution est malmené il y a une
volonté pour un passage en force
d'où la désignation du président par
intérim pour 90 jours
avec une telle crise 90 jours qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire on peut organiser des
élections vincee certes mais quand on
voit ces jeunes là ils n'ont pas leur
carte électorale
il faut faire un recensement électoral
ça décide plus de 90 jours art son
électoral parce que pour les intégrer
dans le jeu politique
il faut leur dire que leur que votre
vote compte
je vous pose la question qui finalement
était sous tendue par ce que parce que
vous disiez à l'instant changera de
geoffrey
qu'est ce qui fait que cette fois la
révolte que l'algérie a déjà connu en
1988 aurait des raisons d'aboutir si
vous voulez à alger les émeutes
d'octobre 88 c'était la jeunesse pauvre
qui a été peut être instrumentalisée
cela s'est beaucoup plus large
mais là c'est le pack heures quand vous
avez 15 à 20 millions de personnes dans
toutes les villes et toutes les régions
c'est souvent il ya eu le printemps auxi
kabyle alors dadis et la kabylie donc
c'est les français
après l'algérie l'algérie
postindépendance n'a jamais que la non
mais aussi massif aussi voilà jamais là
c'est tout le monde tient peuple c'est
le blog qui manifestent en alsace je ne
faisais partie de khenchela
c'est à dire une partie désolé de
richmond la partie orientale on
s'attendait absolument pas top
alors née à la trousse vous sur 7 sur
cette question qu'est ce que vous
craignez le plus fait parce que parce
que finalement on pose la question aux
environs de la manière dont les choses
pourraient évoluer
c'est là le risque sécuritaire
c'est finalement que le mouvement
s'étiole quels sont les risques
aujourd'hui pour ce mouvement
d'ouverture de la société algérienne
le risque sécuritaire c'est un risque à
court terme les manifestants avec
lesquels
il m'a été donné de discuter avec le
renseignement avec les politiques avec
des personnels de l'armée une disent
tous à peu près la même chose et c'est
assez rare qui ait unanimité pour pour
le saluer on a vécu on a vaincu le
terrorisme
une fois on saura faire une deuxième
fois donc ce risque là il peut
effectivement y avoir une attaque ici ou
là on le perçoit pas aujourd'hui comme
un traumatisme majeur on estime que si
on a pu surmonter la décennie noire
on saura faire face à ce risque là le
deuxième risque à mon sens il est pour
moi davantage politique politiques et
diplomatiques d'abord sur le diplo
l'algérie occupe une place importante
donc je vous décrivais des élites qui ne
venaient pas tout tous qui ne parlait
pas toutes de la même voix qui n'avaient
pas toutes les mêmes intérêts on
commence à apercevoir que la russie
lance des messages à la france en disant
rester en dehors de la transition
française etc
depardon il de la transition algérienne
donc du coup ceux éventuellement ces
interférences diplômés dans la situation
où se retrouve l'algérie de aussi moyen
terme pour le mali la tunisie la libye
c'est un risque
compliqué pour la région mais c'est pas
pour le pays en chine mais sur le pays
plus précisément mois ce qui
m'inquièterait le plus c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas de discours politique à ce
conflit là qu'au final on est une
élection qu'ils soient jugés plus ou
moins pas transparent pas libre avec des
candidats qui auraient eu le temps de
s'organiser donc qui ne serait pas issu
de ce mouvement qui a été finalement
assez soudain et que derrière on se
retrouve à un point en fait de départ où
la constitution reste contestée où les
partis politiques ne retrouve pas une
voix et où le champ politique en réalité
se joue à la règle du plus fort
c'est-à-dire entre l'armée la police je
crois qu'il est très difficile de faire
des pronostics parce que nous sommes
devant un phénomène absolument
incroyable extrêmement rare en histoire
en dehors des 289
nous sommes devant une révolution c'est
à dire c'est tout un peuple qui se lève
non pas une partie qui prend les armes
comme en 54 avec le fln mais c'est tout
un peuple il ne se contentera pas comme
dit ma collègue d'une élection où on va
voir revenir d'anciens caciques plus ou
moins déguisés la faune qui se passe en
tunisie a très rapidement avant
l'élection il ya concrètement dans les
90 jours qui commence qui ont commencé
la question des 3 b c'est-à-dire la
question d'un ancien d'un certain nombre
de personnalités liées au régime est
liée à la personnalité de bouteflika et
à ses proches qui vont tenter de
s'accrocher et là il ya un risque
immédiat
on va pas attendre les élections pour
savoir si ce passage en force dont tu
parlais finalement va être tentés ou pas
merci en tout cas à tous les quatre de
nous avoir éclairé sur effectivement ce
qui est une révolution qui est en cours
de nous avoir éclairé dans cette
perspective historique on a bien compris
que les mémoires et est souvent
empoisonné et que cela avait des
conséquences très concrètes sur des
conséquences politiques
aujourd'hui je renvoie à plusieurs
ouvrages d'abord de votre pierre
vermeren
le choc des décolonisations de la guerre
d'algérie au printemps arabe c'est chez
odile jacob
jean-charles geoffrey vous avez publié
vous aussi chez odile jacob
la guerre d'algérie les combattants
français et leur mémoire
préfacé par jean françois sirinelli
naoufel ben rayana milly france-algérie
50 ans d'histoires secrètes c'est le
deuxième tome 1 qui couvre la période
1992 2000 17 je renvoie également au
livre de rémy madoui qu'on voyait dans
le documentaire j'ai été fellaghas
déserteurs français et membre de
officier français mais déserteurs
également y membres de l'ouest pendant
quelques jours de l' os au fln livre de
rémy madoui c'est au seuil et ça a été
publié en 2004 merci à tous les quatre
et bien évidemment à jeune afrique
représenté ici par neila latrous à un
monde en doc se poursuit sur public
sénat et d'abord d'abord cette histoire
bouleversante de rachel c'est une femme
qui se bat depuis des années maintenant
pour récupérer la garde de ses enfants
les services sociaux ont cru à de la
maltraitance il s'agit en fait d'enfants
autistes
rachel l'autisme à l'épreuve de la
justice c'est un film de marion angers
los santos puis alors où l'on reparle
des risques d'une crise financière
nous allons faire un saut en arrière
retour en 2008 dans les coulisses de la
faillite de lehman brothers avec les
témoignages de ceux qui ont tenté
d'éviter cette crise les lanceurs
dallaire plus inside lehman brothers
film de jennifer deschamps excellent
week end à sur public sénat
public sénat avec le soutien de
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel
vous représentez un monde en doc